okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
and i'm happy to try and answer
questions about either
history of science and technology in
times where i've personally been
involved
or from distant past where i might have
researched certain areas of history and
be able to talk about them
so we have a number of questions
saved up from previous times
uh gosh there's one here from binary
saying what sort of math
was ancient india up to
i don't know all those details i will
say a few things about the history of
for example indian mathematics
some extent also chinese mathematics but
particularly indian mathematics
um
one of the challenges in history
from that part of the world
is well in
history
greek
roman
those kinds of
periods
things got dated you kind of know this
was in the you know the system of dates
often at least in the roman empire was
you know it tended to be the nth
year of so-and-so's of emperor
so-and-so's reign or whatever that was
so-called regular dates were the usual
way of stating dates for things and
eventually we're going to have those
emotional alpha we still don't quite
have those yet but um uh
things you know a lot of things got
dated so you know when they're from
uh it tended to be the case
in indian
traditions
that there will be some document some
some uh
some some thing not not really document
that because the the original documents
are never preserved they're always
copies of copies of copies but there
will be some
uh
you know
um
i would have a thing or whatever it is
which had been passed down through many
generations
but it didn't have it didn't come with a
date so you don't really know when it
was from so that's one of the challenges
is and and it could be off by 500 years
sometimes
um
another thing
is that
it's always a challenge
to
take
a modern version of some set of ideas
and try and
connect them with a much older
quite different
sort of paradigmatic framework and quite
different presentational framework in
which those ideas were given in the past
so for example i was looking at
something recently
one of the things that was done in
ancient india
uh is
the development of a kind of systematic
grammar for sanskrit
um
and there's a person called panini who
uh
developed such a grammar and i thought
i'm curious to what extent people sort
of say this is a grammar
that looks like the modern sort of
production rule grammars that we know
originated around 1956
for both generative grammar for human
languages and grammars for computer
languages i'm curious how similar what
panini wrote
for his grammar for sanskrit
was to those productionable grammars so
i
fairly recently went back and looked at
some of this
and
it's really hard to interpret because
the grammar is written out as
essentially a series of aphorisms
okay well that's not that different from
a production rule but often they're
given as things where they are an
example like verbs work this way
now that's sort of like the production
rules we have where there are kind of
pattern variables in the production rule
but it sort of isn't quite like that
because it says verbs work this way and
it could be this or this or this and you
kind of can infer from that that the
this or this or this that there's a a
piece that's fixed and a piece that
changes and so that's kind of the
pattern variable but you're starting to
then have to make inferences about what
kind of the the cognitive structure that
was being described was
uh and you know how does that relate to
the modern version of production rules
what's the essential aspect of
production rules for a modern grammar
how did it compare to to what was being
done there now it's my impression
that i i
personally tried to to understand some
of this like for about for example the
fibonacci series
so
the origin that we kind of have well
nailed down for that is from leonardo
fibonacci in around 12
1202 maybe something like that
where
you know fibonacci was a was a person in
i guess venice primarily was it
pisa i forget somewhere somewhere in
italy um
who um
uh
oh it's pisa actually now they think
about it um
he um
one of his big achievements
was to bring hindu arabic numerals
to the west
before that time you know you wrote down
a number it was written down typically
in roman numerals
what leonardo fibonacci did was to say
you know hindu arabic numerals are
really a better way to do this he wrote
a book called libra abachi the book of
the abacus
and what he's probably most famous for
today was at the very end of that book
is this kind of word problem about
rabbits and the word problem about
rabbits generates the fibonacci series
one one two three you know the series
that says the nth value is the sum of
the n minus one value plus the m minus
second value and he had a word problem
version of that about rabbits and
different seasons and and reproduce
reproducing rabbits and so on
but any case the so that's the origin
that we know is fibonacci libra barchy
the libero bache book it's well dated
it's kind of been passed down we kind of
know how it originated
but
the fibonacci series is something which
you know i don't know i think uh
if if the fiance series hadn't been a
known thing i would have discovered it
in my life at least 10 times
because it's something that kind of
naturally shows up in lots of kinds of
problems
and it also naturally showed up in
essentially mathematics that was done in
ancient india
and
the um
in particular it showed up in the study
of prozadie that is the study of kind of
how you uh when you create
a
a piece of sort of um
well musical poet poetry that you set to
music so to speak there's the question
of how you kind of scan the poetry so
for example i don't know for the for the
indian case but in the case of um uh of
greek for example or latin
there are in greek there are things like
you know iambic pentameters and things
which are uh you know the pentameter
means the five feet in the meter and
it'll be in a long short short or
something like that
um will be there'll be a bunch of long
short short long short you know et
cetera et cetera et cetera things that
go in a particular line of a poem just
like i don't know in english a
limerick's or something have a
particular way of going of of being
structured um in that way i think but in
any case and it was at least i know for
latin greek it was a kind of a thing
that was done was to have a certain
rhythm of the poetry that was based on
where their long vowels were their short
vowels and so on i guess the same thing
was done in in probably in sanskrit um
and uh so
the question was asked well what are how
many possible forms of the long short
short long et cetera et cetera et cetera
are there and the answer to that is as
fibonacci numbers and that was something
that apparently was was looked at in
kind of ancient times in india again i
haven't looked at that source material
and it's often challenging to to know
you know somebody might say
in that particular case it's probably
quite easy to decode it probably says
you know the number of possible poems is
given by and that'll probably have a
word description of something where
maybe it gives the recursive formula i
don't know exactly how it works maybe it
gives examples of the numbers i'm not
sure again how exactly how it works
but that's probably a fairly easy one to
kind of pick out
of kind of the ancient uh works and see
yes it really is something just like
modern fibonacci
i would say you know the effort to
figure out did did something get figured
out at a certain time in history and can
you tell
you know i remember a number of years
ago i was uh
visiting the uh leibniz archive you know
leibniz was a person who had many things
to say about kind of the the early ideas
of computation in the late 1600s and he
had this idea of the characteristic of
universe solace this kind of universal
language for representing things sort of
symbolically and so my kind of slightly
joke uh statement was let me see if i
can look through his manuscripts and see
if there's a touring machine in there
and
just as a footnote to this you know
leibniz was a person who had um
written many
uh
he was a bit of a disorganized writer
you know he discovered many interesting
things among them pieces of calculus
invented the integral sign lots of kinds
of things like that um he also had a lot
of ideas about logic and knowledge and
he kind of would have done wolf alpha
probably if he'd been 300 years later
and had the technology to do it
but
leibniz was a bit disorganized in terms
of his um
uh
um
his way of um
um
presenting things
and um
he uh
uh
um
he was um um
the uh
and so
unlike some other sort of um well-known
scientists philosophers or whatever of
old who had very systematic books
that they presented things and leibniz
had it was much less organized but
anyway this question of could i find a
turing machine in the works of leibniz
some kind of idealization of computation
it's a challenging thing i think the
answer is no it's not there
but
it's hard to know that for sure because
his explanations were not that clear
his
uh
you know there's a lot of you know he
has weird little sketches in the margin
and he has all kinds of things where
it's written rather obscurely and did he
have the idea or not have the idea well
i don't think he had that specific idea
um
it's you know leibniz himself i i would
say that his his reputation um
you know voltaire i think kind of made
fun of leibniz and talked about him
having talked about you know
what did he call him doctor what was the
name i forget um uh sort of
really emphasized leibniz is the world
is the best of all possible worlds type
thing which i'm not sure was quite
what he really meant in his kind of
philosophical description i mean i
realized recently with leiden it's just
to give a sense of the difficulty of
projecting backwards
from modern understanding to what people
thought in the past
leibniz was very big on this idea that
the world somehow the world is made of
monads
you know things like i don't know some
modern functional programming languages
have picked up the word monad just as a
um uh
as a as something a little bit as a
rather different kind of thing but
leibniz had this idea of a monad and for
years i've been trying to figure out
what the heck is a leibniz monad
because one of the things that he would
talk about how sort of the world is made
up of monads and all that matters is
kind of the relative positions of monads
and so on
and the key thing that just had me
totally confused was that as i
understand it from the translations that
i've seen in leibniz
he describes
monads as each lemonade has a
consciousness
well by the time we're talking about
that it's like i don't know what nerf
that means we're talking about sort of
some kind of atoms in space
atoms of space maybe that's somewhat
similar to what we've been doing in our
physics project but they have each have
a consciousness it's like help that's
far away from what i understand about
how things work
but
what i realized recently is when he said
that and i need to go back and look at
the original latin
and see whether the translation was what
confused that
when he says consciousness what he means
is i think
they do something and they do something
spontaneously
and in fact that's bizarrely similar to
what we talk about in our current model
of physics where we talk about atoms of
space with these connections and rules
being applied and the rules are just
doing something that the rules just get
applied
and it could be that what leibniz had in
mind when he said every monad has a
consciousness it's just every monad
spontaneously does something and it
could be very much the same kind of
thing as as every sort of every
connected collection of atoms of space
just does something
so that's a place where again this issue
about sort of back projecting and
interpreting things is quite hard
because leibniz didn't really had he
didn't have the metaphor of our modern
computers where he says you apply a rule
you run a program he didn't have that
metaphor because he didn't have
computers i have to say i was really
struck when i was visiting the leibniz
archive what leibniz it was a sort of a
tried a practical effort he made a out
of brass he made a four function
mechanical calculator and it spent like
30 years trying to debug the thing and
get it really to work it was really very
charming to read his essentially
marketing material for this calculator
about how it is you know it will save
lots of time and so on it's kind of like
big sheets of paper with essentially
marketing blurbs for the calculator but
it wasn't ever very practical because it
was just a difficult piece of
engineering particularly difficult to do
carries mechanically because when you're
when you're trying to you have just one
number that you're sort of trying to one
wheel that is representing one one one
position in a positional number you as
if you carry then you've got to turn one
wheel and it's got to entrain the the
turning of many other wheels and that's
just mechanically difficult to achieve
and you know the forces don't work out
easily and so on and leibniz had lots of
trouble with that um but uh
let's see what i was what i was going to
say was that in sort of in the back room
at least when i visited the leibniz
archive was the you know the brass
calculator
and i was realizing in in leibniz's time
that was the only computer-like thing he
had ever seen
whereas in today's world
it's like we've got billions of
computers i have to say as i was
thinking about that as i was looking at
that i was thinking
what will today's we've got billions of
computers
what will that look like or sound like
to somebody in the future
and i think the answer is
people will say
well you only had billions of computers
now everything is made of computers
you know in today's world when we have
materials
they are just molecules that are just
set up to just sit there as molecules so
to speak and have various chemical or
physical properties or whatever but i
suspect that one of the things when we
finally figured out figure out and i
think actually i have some ideas in
recent times about this how to do
molecular scale computing it will be the
case that even within those individual
molecules instead of a piece of plastic
you'll have this thing made of molecules
where the molecules have essentially are
programmable to do computations at the
at a molecular scale and so to leibniz
you know he saw one computer in today's
world we see i know in the room i'm in
right now i don't know how many
computers there are some number of tens
of computers probably
um the um
in uh uh in the future my guess is that
one will say sort of essentially one
will everything will be made of
computers so to speak but any case the i
think the original question that was
asked was about math in ancient india
and uh there are a few other things that
i i i know about that but it's a i have
to say it's a bit sketchy so i'm i
probably shouldn't uh shouldn't
volunteer the the the uh sketchy things
i know about that um i will i will just
say that this whole question
that comes up is you know oh such and
such an idea was it actually invented by
you know ancient indian sage x
or was it really invented you know a
thousand years later
by
uh somebody in italy or something
and
you might think that was easy to answer
but it's often not
it's often not in the case of indian
material because of the dating problem
uh it's often not because it's very hard
to tell
you know was that aphorism that was
written down was that really the essence
of the idea that we now understand in
this or that way or not that's a
challenging thing to figure out and
sometimes to even have any hope of
figuring that out you have to have a
huge amount of context
of what was the sort of ambient
understanding of things
in that time in india and so on and
again that's a that's a challenging
thing i mean it reminds me of the
problem
of uh some of the things that i've done
in science people say quite often
oh that resonates with some particular
area of kind of eastern
uh
thought
and that's often really challenging for
me to decode almost impossible for me to
decode because you know i've grown up in
kind of a western
science-oriented tradition so to speak
which has a certain way of talking about
things and when somebody says well
you know this is
uh
you know
they talk about how the world you know
how there's a soul that is the whole
universe and things like this and that
has a very
you know has probably a very clear
meaning if you've sort of grown up in
this kind of culture where that's just
part of what is discussed but it's
really hard to understand um coming from
uh sort of the the western i don't know
analytical tradition or something and so
i i think that that's another thing that
kind of bites one in trying to
understand you know what was understood
about let's say mathematics um at some
time thousands of years ago uh in india
for example and um uh you know it's an
interesting question whether for example
there could have been sort of big
developments in mathematics
that are either lost completely
like there are no written records
or
developments where even they are right
there
you know in one's face type thing
but one just doesn't recognize them
today i mean i think um uh you know
people will find in you know i don't
know in the
uh
sort of uh various particularly jewish
writings people will tend to find you
know oh there's this amazing
numerological coincidence there's this
thing where these you know you look at
these letters of this and that and the
other and and it turns out you you come
to some conclusion
and it's really hard to tell for many of
those things
what
you know is this meaningful is this
something just coincidental is it sort
of back projected from what we know
today what's really going on or is this
in a kind of an intellectual framework
that we just don't have anymore today
i mean it reminds one of the general
problem of sort of the interpretation of
archaeology
it's like you know when you see these
stones what were they for
well if they are for something that we
do today
then yes we understand these stones was
for this or that
but if they're just stones that let's
say it's an arrowhead it's carved in a
certain way and it looks just like a
modern arrowhead we have a continuous
chain of kind of development of
arrowheads and we can kind of see how
that worked but if you've just got a few
stones arranged in the ground and they
they go this way or that way
what was this for you know take
something like stonehenge in in england
you know it's a circle of stones um and
you know what exactly was this for i
don't know i think there are probably
progressively better theories for that
but
uh and then there are questions like
was these were these set of stones set
up this way to align with
some particular configuration of the sun
at the equinox or something like this
or were they just put that way you know
in other words it could be well they
meant to align it for the equinox but
they were off by five degrees
well does that actually mean they
aligned it for the equinox or is it just
a completely random orientation which
happens to be five degrees away from how
it should be aligned for the equinox and
that's really hard to tell
and you know it it's some
it's it's the same kind of thing when
you see you know if you wonder were
there any sort of lost traditions of
mathematics for example where you see
things where sort of things fit together
in a certain way but whether was that
intentional was that not intentional is
that significant it might be significant
in a in a framework that we don't have
anymore reminds me of another example of
something like that the pythagoreans 5th
century bc or so um you know they had a
kind of this pythagoras had this kind of
well
probably somewhat peculiar cult-like
set up
but
he had
uh he had things about numbers like for
him every number had a significance you
know there was a male female
i don't remember what all the all the
different
meanings for the different numbers were
and so for pythagoras
he had this thing called the tetractys
which was
the
fact that one plus two plus three
uh let's see plus
am i getting this right one plus three
one plus
two plus three plus four
as uh oh yeah that is equal to ten right
the that's the pythagorean tetractus
and for pythagoras that was very
significant
because each number
was sort of a had a significance
in the world at large
and so that was a statement about
something about the world which to us
today just seems nuts
but
at that time there was a framework in
which that made sense
now that led pythagoras
to be very interested in perfect numbers
for example
numbers which are equal to the sum of
their divisors
perfect numbers have not been
particularly important
in the general tradition of mathematics
as it's come down to us today
primes on the other hand uh have been
very important but for whatever reason
perfect numbers have not been so
important but but to pythagoras with a
different kind of cognitive framework
for the significance of numbers perfect
numbers were probably much more
important than primes
so it's this whole question about sort
of how you contextualize the things
you're talking about and what seems
significant at a certain time what does
it mean how do you deduce whether it had
significance and so on you know i think
an interesting question if you went and
you know if you could uh have your your
impossible to build time machine and go
have a conversation with pythagoras
and uh uh you know start talking about
math
it could be that that you know
eighty percent of what pythagoras would
say
will be math where we say we don't care
it doesn't make any sense with our
current interpretation of what numbers
are and so on and only twenty percent
might be math that has survived and that
we care about in the context that we do
math today
all right long answer that let's see
uh
oh boy all kinds of questions here
as a question from arc
how were modern shipping containers
standardized what are some of the
advantages of optimal standardized
packaging i don't know the specific
history of modern shipping containers
um it is always interesting
the way that standardization happens or
doesn't happen
i mean a famous one is railway gauges
you know
if you're gonna
by the time you have a railway with a
certain distance between the rails
you're gonna make you know railway cars
that have their wheels that distance
apart
and you definitely don't want a
situation where you know you have part
of a country with with rails that are
some distance apart another part with
rails or a different distance apart i
mean it's still the case
it certainly used to be the case i don't
know if it is today
that in different parts of europe where
things are still you know land connected
so to speak there are different gauges
of railways i think in russia relative
to other places i think that was the
case
um and you'd literally you'd be on a
train and they'd have to they'd have to
swap out
the kind of the the wheel part of the of
the rail cars
because it's going to a different gauge
of railway and that's clearly very
inconvenient
and so this question of sort of how do
you drive standardization there's
certain kinds of things that that drive
standardization like the inconvenience
and the expense of having to switch out
different you know railcar kinds of
things
i think um
in the case of uh
i'm trying to remember i think i
yeah i remember i remember when we were
working on will from alpha um maybe a
decade ago now and putting in
information about shipping containers i
remember uh noting all of the um uh the
various different standards for the for
shipping containers i mean the main
point about shipping containers
is that uh you know on it used to be the
case that you would kind of
load your cargo onto a ship and somebody
would just take the pieces of cargo and
put them on the ship
and
the but then people realize it's much
more efficient to load everything into a
container and then just take the whole
container and stick it on the ship and
so modern ships you know it's kind of
they're remarkable to see but they're
just a giant collection of container
bricks
all built up
and um uh you know when they're
obviously there are a bunch of ships
that are having trouble getting their
containers loaded and unloaded in
today's specific world but but um in
general it's a it's a very uh you know
impressive kind of almost robotic
process
the loading of you know
unload containers from a ship put them
on train cars you know start them going
to their destinations and so on and i
think the um clearly one of the issues
is if you're going to put containers on
a ship and you want them to fit together
properly you want those containers to
all be the same size because you want
them to pack perfectly it's like saying
if you have a bunch of uh
equal rectangles it's easy to pack the
equal rectangles on the plane but if you
start having rectangles of different
sizes you're like oh well we can fit
this into this gap here and so on and so
on and so on and it's it's kind of like
you have to do a memory allocation on a
computer or something do things fit in
this gap or not or whatever else it's
much more difficult and you don't have
sort of the optimal use of
the space
but
it's always interesting to see kind of
how standardization happens
and you know occasionally they'll be
sort of something we'll be kind of
teetering on two different sides you
know will it standardize this way or
will it standardize that way i mean
sometimes standardization
is
is
standardization is both good for the
world and bad for the world it's good
because it makes certain things more
streamlined it's bad because it means
that's the way it's going to be for the
next x number of hundreds of years until
there's a major disruption in the way
that technology works because the cost
of a change is so great
and you know there are things where
things have been standardized and the
standards are actually a pretty bad idea
i happen to think that about the ieee
floating point standard for arithmetic
but that's what all hardware for
computers is built using and we're stuck
with it for the foreseeable future
because the cost of change is immense
and there's a giant stack of technology
that's been built on top of that and i'm
sure even for the detailed size and
shape of shipping containers i'm sure
there's endless you know port facilities
that have been built very specific to
that particular size
and um uh it's some you know all kinds
of and so it becomes extremely difficult
to change um and and you know i kind of
wonder sometimes you know standards that
get set i mean i've been involved well
i've only been directly involved in one
standard setting effort and it was
horrifying and i kind of decided from
that i'm never going to be involved in
such a thing again it was a standard for
the way math has rendered on the web
mathml
um
and uh you know we it was kind of a
a
thing where we had done a lot of work
actually developing kind of methods for
rendering two-dimensional math and so on
and uh
when people are interested in sort of
having a standard for how to do it on
the web
i said well you know we've done a lot of
work on this we can contribute this
we're happy to see that be used on the
web and then it's like well let's be
involved in a standards committee that
does this
and that was just a a
a frustrating experience of the wrong
things being concluded
through pure kind of human politics
having nothing to do with the actual
merits of what should be done so to
speak and i think that is probably very
typical of the way certain kinds of
standards get made i mean at other times
it's kind of a de facto standard where
just there is for example commercial
success of something and so it becomes a
standard for for some particular kind of
thing but i would say that that in uh
you know standards make for efficiency
but standards also make for
inflexibility
um
let's see
well there's a question here i'm not
sure it's completely relevant to this
topic but about some
math papers including the improving the
workflow for math papers
as opposed to writing latex and reading
pdf
you know
i would let's talk a little bit about
history of that okay
so back in the day
even when i was younger
the only way people sort of
presented math was they wrote it
hand wrote it
and what happened to it well there are
several technologies that kind of
developed around that
the first technology was the i guess ibm
selectric typewriters because usually
you have a typewriter you know i had a
typewriter and the typewriter you know i
lived in england and
at the time when i was using typewriter
i was living in england and it was a
standard qwerty keyboard with uh you
know that typed the standard letters of
the um
uh of the english alphabet so to speak
with a few little hacks on it like for
example
my typewriter had no one key one digit
key because the lowercase l looked like
a one so that was the thing you typed to
get a one um and uh you know various
little hacks like that but basically it
was
the standard english alphabet
so now the question was well what if you
wanted to type an alpha or a lambda or
something like this how would you do
that
um the technology that developed for
that i think
developed by ibm
was this notion of the sort of golf ball
typewriter so in an ordinary typewriter
right you have you know you press the
key and there's a lever and it it
it presses it has a there's a long piece
of metal with a with a with a kind of a
the little font character at the end of
it and that kind of hits
the through the ribbon hits the piece of
paper at the place where you're
currently typing and for those who don't
know this um i i think this is only
going to be one of these things that's
eventually lost to time you know the
notion of a carriage return right that
was literally the carriage in which the
the um you know the paper was held on
this
of a typewriter and as you typed every
letter you typed it would move the
carriage
um slightly to the to the left if you're
typing in english as um as you as you
move the letter to go further on the
right of the piece of paper and the
carriage return was a lever on the side
that you would you would move the lever
and that would release uh sort of the
ratchet that would allow you to move the
this whole carriage that had the paper
on it
all the way back to the left so that you
could start typing on the next line
again and hence the carriage return
concept
but um
but so the question was with that kind
of you just got these these big gum
uh
um
you know all the keys are built into the
typewriter but then the idea was this
kind of interchangeable golf ball
typewriter idea
where instead of having these long metal
sort of prongs that had letters at the
end of it the idea was you have this
sort of golf ball thing and what would
happen is the golf ball was close to the
ribbon and the golfer would turn around
to a different orientation
to expose a particular letter and then
hit the ribbon and so that was kind of
the idea of a way to to have sort of a
different presentation of letters for
the typewriter and that meant that when
you were typing something that didn't
just have
uh
that didn't just have um uh english
letters in it when you got to the greek
letters you would you would
take undo the latch pull out the golf
ball put another golf ball in there and
then you'd have to remember oh the
lambda is the such and such key that you
press on the um uh
on the typewriter keyboard but then it
would be using the the greek letter golf
ball and so you get a greek letter typed
on um
on the um
um
uh on on the piece of paper i do have to
tell one story which just uh reminds me
people have some questions here about
about dick feynman and um
uh back in the day when when i worked at
caltech
um the departmental assistant a woman
named helen tuck
um who uh uh is no longer alive
unfortunately but um a very very lively
individual um she was the assistant to
both dick feynman and murray galman and
the departmental assistant and she would
type people's papers and when i was
writing papers physics papers in the
late 1970s at caltech
helen was the person who who typed those
papers for me
and on her
you know ibm's electric typewriter with
the golf ball thing and the greek
letters and so on and
it's kind of a funny clash of cultures
because i had this paper where it was a
calculation of something in qcd
and i had done the calculation a lot
with computers
and so and i had done algebraic
calculations with a computer and that
meant that i had all kinds of weird
numbers you know
342 pi cubed minus 964
or whatever
um
and uh
the um
in this so somehow
in this in this document there were just
a lot of nines in the document and you
know my handwriting isn't great it's not
absolutely terrible but it's it's not
great but anyway helen typed every
single nine in my document she typed as
a g and i said to her why did you do
that she said well these papers they
never have nines in them
now of course now they think about it
benford's law which tells one the
typical distribution of first first
digits and numbers tells one that one is
much more common than than nine there's
a log distribution of
of of numbers typically of sort of
naturally generated numbers um just by
virtue of the fact that if you pick a
number sort of independent of size the
ones that fall in the in the early part
of a a kind of a a a
exponent of 10 reduced thing they'll
tend to be more with ones than them but
anyway now they realize it that this was
benford's law bytes
plus
the kind of culture clash of of actually
doing computations algebraic
computations with a computer caused
helen to type all my nines as g's a big
nuisance that was required retyping of
course the big technology in those days
was that um uh normally you know when i
had a typewriter i was normally you just
have this ribbon that just had black on
it and then i was very excited at some
point when i was a kid when i got a
typewriter that could have a black and
red ribbon and so you would kind of
shift there would be a sort of shift
thing you could press that would cause
the next letter you type to not be uh to
not hit the black part of the ribbon but
to hit the red part of the ribbon so you
get a red letter so to speak on your um
on your piece of paper
but anyway the other big innovation was
that in addition to a black ribbon you
could also have a white ribbon in fact
you could have something where if you
were had just typed a letter and it was
wrong you would backspace over that
letter and then you would be able to
type the white version of that letter
there so that you would cover the black
ink that was down on the paper with
white
kind of um it used to be called the
brand name at least in england but you
could sort of do this by hand you would
have these little sheets it was called
tip x in british english i don't know
what it was called in in the us
where you would um take one of these
little
pieces of kind of white stuff
and you would it's kind of a white
uh piece of paper which had sort of
white um
um
essentially white die on one side and
you would put that in your typewriter uh
where the um uh where the where the key
would hit um and then instead of it
would hit through the black ribbon it
would hit this white thing which would
then put white onto a piece of paper but
it became it also there started to be
typewriters that would actually have
white ribbons in them so you could do
that correction directly without having
to get out your little sheet of tip x or
whatever and put it in the typewriter in
any case the um i mean the other
technology you know if i look at
manuscripts of papers that i wrote back
in those days the the technologies that
i used tended to be a lot of scotch tape
a lot of uh these sort of avery label
type things and a certain amount of
white out of where you would get this
kind of white
paint like stuff and and sort of uh you
know white out what you've written but
mostly
a lot of papers in today's world i i you
know i'll i'll type something and then
i'll backspace across it and you know
that that's and it's gone um actually i
tend to
try and store bigger pieces that i wrote
in some outtakes uh file and so on but
but in any case just in case i need to
go back to them although they're always
they always have change control and all
kinds of other stuff in the in modern
times but um in ancient times when i
would write some manuscript i would end
up with more and more and more layers as
i would take you know some sentence oh i
don't like that sentence i write it out
again i stick the piece of paper on top
of the previous one and so on so i
suspect there are um it's kind of like
um uh in ancient manuscripts you often
find things where people are written
over written over and written over
something i'm sure there are early
drafts of papers of mine that are that
are now sort of under the scotch tape so
to speak um from these kind of rather
thick often uh manuscripts oh and then
then the other thing that's right the
other thing i did when they got too
thick i photocopied them and then then
they would be a single sheet again
okay anyway we're talking about math
type setting well
what happened
when you would write a paper
you would uh
you would eventually
um you would get it typed
and then you would send it into a
journal
and in those days there was real work to
be done by journals because they had to
actually take that typewritten thing and
instead of just having camera-ready copy
and just photographing it or you know
rendering it on on a photo type setter
or something um instead of that or just
uh they would they would have to
actually typeset
the um the paper which means they
actually have to get
uh some kind of well in the in really
ancient times it was with individual
pieces of lead type but then it became
photo orthography where they would have
to take one of these machines that
specifies you know uh how you uh
lay out type and so on and take what you
would what was in your typed written
version of your paper so it went from
manuscript to typescript and then to
actual printed versions
well how was that actually done
well there were folks who were
typesetters who worked for journals and
who got very expert at taking those
things that people had
had typed with the typewriter and maybe
added little by hand
uh you know pieces to them
and
uh then
you know what i'm trying to think when
when i first wrote papers
i'm wondering whether i actually hand
wrote the formulas when i sent them into
journals i kind of think i might have
done um any case so that the typesetters
at journals had to actually decode all
of that stuff and turn it into nice
tight things
now one thing that's interesting is that
people who did that kind of typesetting
were not they were crafts people of
artisans
who were typesetters they were not math
experts particularly and so it's rather
charming that the the names of sort of
the math characters end up being based
on what they look like like i remember
the things called fences an offense like
a a an absolute value sign which is just
a vertical bar you know i think it's
usually called a fence for
for um in typesetting these were things
that were described by their appearance
because that's you know if you don't
need to know what the math means that's
a perfectly that's a much more effective
way to know oh i'm seeing this in this
paper i want to pick up the the fence to
put in this place uh to do the setting
so that was kind of the the first uh
sort of big thing for that that journals
would do
for um
for typesetting
then the big innovation was when
there was computerized type setting
and i think the first really significant
system along those lines was called
t-roff
and it was part of the
early unix operating system developed at
bell labs
and there was a thing called enroth and
a thing called tiroff
and they both had a certain sort of
description language
for representing you know this and then
a superscript and the subscript and so
on and so on and so on and t rough was
was rendered for a photo type setting
machine so it would convert from that
specification language into the raw uh
code needed for a photo type setting
machine enroll would do an approximation
based on sort of ascii art of what that
would look like as a as a thing that was
to be rendered and for example i think
unix documentation if you look at the
man pages under linux and things like
that i'm pretty sure those are still
formatted using nrf
um but anyway so that was a thing
and certainly papers that i wrote
uh starting in about
when was it uh probably
well i think the the documentation for
smp was done in t roth
so that was um in fact it's an
interesting question whether i have the
original files from that and whether it
could be converted to modern notebooks i
don't know any case the um uh
that that was in 1979 so by 1979 i was
using t roth and i used that for
a bunch of my early papers about um
cellular automata and complexity and
computation and physics and so on
um i think i uh meanwhile at that time
don knuth
had decided as as his
don has had this project
to write his multi-volume art of
computer programming
was i think he he told me recently that
um
uh
about some particular topic
that it wasn't in his 1962 table of
contents so it wasn't going to be in the
books
but he started it's a it's a sort of
remarkable story he started what was
going to be an eight volume series of
books about sort of everything that was
known in computer science
started i think in 1962 and the first
volumes i think came out in like 1968
and uh it's been kind of a lifelong
project for for don to do this he's he i
think things kind of went a little bit
off the rails when he got to volume four
and i i you know he's been producing
these fascicles little micro pieces of
volume four and i think it's split into
four a b c and so on and then it got
little fascicles of that and it's like a
it's not obvious that the um that the
end is not receding faster than things
are getting written but um hopefully the
um uh he'll
it'll be um uh in his lifetime he'll
he'll get the whole thing written it's a
it's a very remarkable work of
scholarship um
and uh he and i do share a lot of
interest in in sort of the history of
ideas and um
uh um and um
and those kinds of things but um
in in as well as a bunch of content
about about some uh about science and
one thing uh
uh
it's a it's an amusing fact that these
things in term rewriting systems this
clue spandex completion procedure and
other features of term rewriting systems
which don knew studied as a matter of
theoretical computer science have become
deeply relevant in our physics project
to many very practical things but i
digress
in in the effort to typeset his art of
computer programming don got frustrated
with existing systems and so did what
many of us do in those kinds of
situations and decided to build his own
and develop tech as well as a thing
called metafont which is a font design
system
and
that has become very widely used and
i have to say when we were first
back 33 years ago now when we were first
releasing mathematica one of the things
that we had was a tech form that would
convert which still exists in welfare
language today which will convert
a
mathematical expression into tech
and don had at the time said you know
tech is is small enough and clean enough
there are no bugs in tech and he had
this kind of i think exponentially
increasing bug bounty he was paying out
and i was like i don't think you want us
to to send you these things because as
soon as we started machine generating
tech there were boatloads of bugs
because the tech interpreter had never
seen machine generated tech it had only
seen tech written by humans
but anyway the
the thing that um
uh
that sort of became tech became a
standard for kind of if you know what
the math is supposed to look like here's
how you can say what it should be
a different problem is what if the math
is supposed to mean something what about
if the x superscript 2 is supposed to
mean x squared what's the relationship
between meaningful math and appearance
math and sometimes there might be two
things that mean the same thing but look
different
two things that look different that mean
the same thing and so on um the the uh
uh and the question is is there sort of
a a way
uh can you make
math that both sort of looks like
traditional math and
means the thing you expected to mean so
in the mid 1990s
we did a lot of work on that in version
three of mathematica to build kind of a
a two-dimensional
typesetting system
where you can both enter the input
in a way that is two-dimensional and
have it mean something and so what we
ended up with was a kind of a
two two branches we ended up with what
we call standard form and what we call
traditional form and standard form is
something which has the general
appearance of math with subscripts and
superscripts and built up fractions and
matrices that are laid out in grids with
brands around them and things like that
but it has the feature that
every
every element of standard form
is directly parsable or mean meaningful
in traditional computer languages
they're one-dimensional kinds of things
where you just have a string of
characters and you break them up with
you know interfere into in a
hierarchical way but in our
starting in version three in wolfram
language you can have two-dimensional
syntax
where you are parsing the fact that it's
an x superscript two and that means x
squared and there's some tricky things
there like for example one one problem
was when you do an integral
you
have you know integral okay that's fine
the integrand and then you say dx
what's that d
is it like a traditional communal garden
d that you type on a keyboard well no
that's very hard to parse it's very hard
to make that
unambiguous if you start having things
like you know let's do the integral of d
to the d d d
well that gets really hard to understand
and so what we invented with this thing
we call differential d which is a
different character from an ordinary d
it's typed as a scape dd escape in
in the language um that is something
which is then perfectly possible you've
got the integral sign you've got the
integrand you've got the differential d
which is an operator just like plus as
an operator and that's then a perfectly
possible unit and we had to do the same
thing with imaginary i and so on so that
was then we we represent them as some
kind of double struck version of a d and
it looks sort of visually very close to
what um uh what you would see
in in a sort of standard
math presentation of something but it is
uniquely possible and understandable i
was very amused actually looking at
leibniz's documents that i found uh oh
gosh what was it was one character that
we had invented quite independently as
our way of
of showing that this was a meaningful
character rather than just a letter um
and he had done the same thing although
it was lost in standard mathematical
rotation in the intervening years
but any case so so we had this one
branch which is standard form where the
idea we have this one branch which is
standard form but the idea is there may
be some interpretations like the
differential d
and other kinds of things like that but
it kind of looks roughly it has the
spirit of standard two-dimensional math
but it is perfectly possible and then we
have traditional form which is as close
as possible to what you would see in a
textbook with heuristics about the
ordering of polynomials and who knows
what else that a sort of textbook style
but it's only it's it's sort of
heuristically arranged that way but it's
only but to pause it is not something
you can guarantee to be able to do
because there will be things there like
if you say
sine to the minus 1 x does that mean an
inverse sine an arc sine or does that
mean sine to the minus 1 just a thing
called sine s i n
that happens to be you know that's one
over it and that's what it means to the
power minus one and so on so it's it's a
more heuristic parsing process and we
represent that in a in a notebook by
having a sort of jagged line on the cell
bracket that kind of means warning
danger um you know this is not so easy
to interpret
but actually this question of sort of
natural math understanding kind of like
natural language understanding how do
you take sort of math that people just
type that they uh and understand it well
we do a lot of that in more from alpha
um
and uh of of taking things where people
just sort of split out math notation and
they don't really tell you what it means
and just like they split out natural
language and you have to kind of you
know sort of work backwards to figure
out what it means and often you can do
that
um i think uh
one of the things that i found
interesting if you have
a sort of math where you don't know what
it means
can you typeset it
and one of the things that's interesting
there is a lot of what makes math
typesetting elegant or not is the
precise spacing around operators when
you have a circle plus
or a union or this side or the other how
much space is there around that operator
are all the operands really squashed up
around it or is it does it have a lot of
breathing room
well
and another question is when you type
things in if i type a circle plus b
circle times c
how does that pass
does it pass as the b circle times c is
its own sort of parenthesized unit and
then the a plus is outside that just
like standard order of operations for
plus and times or does it work
differently so one of the things i was
curious about this is in the mid 1990s i
hadn't thought about this in a long time
was when people use mathematical
notation like circle plus circle times
or they use more exotic coproduct
symbols or whatever else
um what
what precedence do they think the
operators have in other words do they
have in their mind something which has
a um
where they are supposing that the circle
times binds tighter than circle plus and
things like this so i spent a whole
bunch of time looking through all kinds
of math books and so on and mathematical
logic is the area with the most exotic
notation um at least at the time it was
i think there'd been some areas of
mathematics that have grown up since
then that have at least equally exotic
notation although perhaps they're areas
where mathematics is kind of rapidly
approaching the kind of logic or
computation point
but any case the um what i found which
surprised me quite a bit was people are
remarkably consistent even when these
operators mean utterly different things
they're remarkably consistent in
thinking that the circle times
uh operator binds tighter than the
circle plus operator and so on and also
that there's a strange correlation
between the amount of breathing space
left around operators and the tightness
of their binding
so we made use of that to be able to let
people type in essentially semantically
meaningless stuff but syntactically
pausable stuff starting in version three
of all from language and it's something
that's that i use with some frequencies
a useful thing to be able to use
something which notationally looks nice
and compact because it has things like
circle times in it and so on but you can
then define your own meaning for it
okay so
that was the story of kind of making
making math meaningful making typeset
math meaningful
um
by the way i would say that when people
were doing back to sort of manual type
setting and for papers and things i
think people used to call that penalty
copy
when they had to do math
because you know when you're
just
putting a piece of text and you're type
setting the text you're like typing out
the text and it's all appearing in a
nicely organized way but when you're
dealing with math oh it's such a pain
you know you've got to
fake move things around and so on it was
called penalty copy because it was copy
as in textual material
that
was like really hard to deal with and so
it's going to cost more et cetera et
cetera et cetera and i think sometimes
when people
they probably still do this i it's what
i get for not publishing in academic
journals for forever and ever i don't
really know these things anymore but it
used to be the case that that one of the
models for
uh
particularly professional societies was
this notion of uh you pay to publish
your paper um and you pay page charges
and they would sometimes compute those
page charges on the basis of you know
how many lines of text versus how many
lines of math they probably still do
that i have no idea that probably even
though today it's all computerized um
and it doesn't really cost anything
different it's probably a a you know
revenue generation
scheme or something i should say back to
um
back to typesetting in journals um the
american math society adopted kind of
tech pretty early but um other places
were less fast to adopt some of these
things and i remember reviews of modern
physics nice journal
from the american physical society i
think um
was
i wrote a big paper for that about
cellular automata
that was in 1983 i guess
and it was interesting because my paper
was the first one
that was sent to them
in tiroff
in electronic form
for
a sort of automatic type setting and
actually in in a way
uh although it was in some ways good
because i had some kind of uh unusual
unexpected physics notation so to speak
in that paper that probably would have
had many iterations going backwards and
forwards correcting proofs if it had
been done not directly in electronic
form but it did have the feature that i
think it was more difficult for them to
um to like size pictures correctly in
the paper and things like that because
it was presented in here often there
were many pieces of back and forth about
the electronic version of that but i was
kind of the the um uh i kind of led in
this effort to make um
uh
the sort of to deliver electronically uh
papers at least to these physics
journals i have to say back in 1986
i started a journal called complex
systems which is still uh prospering
today
and
back in those days i i was sort of the
first journal that had where its
instructions to contributors said things
like you can send
this you know your paper
to us by email through bitnet or uunet
or whatever else a uucp rather
um you know strange email addresses with
exclamation marks in them and so on or
you can send your paper to us on floppy
disks and you can send it in traffic you
can send it in this you can send it in
that
and um i think this led the then editor
of nature magazine john maddox to write
a little editorial called what is an
electronic journal talking about my
journal and being super amused by the
fact that it said things like you know
you can send a floppy disk to us and so
on that's like that's a that's a thing
from the distant future for that time
now of course the embarrassing part of
this was that 25 years later we realized
we hadn't updated the instructions for
contributors maybe it wasn't as much as
25 years but many years later we hadn't
updated the instructions for
contributors for the complex systems
journal so it still talked about floppy
disks
even though
by that time we were getting close to
the moment when kids would say when you
show them a floppy disk
is that a 3d print out of this save icon
um and had no idea what it was but um in
any case that's just that's just the way
that those things go
but you know when we look at sort of the
flow of this idea of journals and the
idea of papers and math and so on you
know the big thing that hasn't happened
that i've been
wanting to get to generally happen for
30 years more than 30 years is this idea
of using notebooks and using computable
uh
having a computational language mixed
with natural language and math language
in papers
and really being able to compute from
papers
and what really makes that possible is
our world language effort and the fact
that it is a computational language not
a programming language aimed at you know
telling a computer in detail what to do
but a computational language aimed at
explaining ideas computationally and as
such it's something that's intended for
humans to read and for computers to read
and a way to have the computer generate
material that you get to put in your
paper and so on and i i've been pushing
for a number of years now this concept
of computational essays as a way to sort
of present material where you can not
only read the text in english but you
can read the computational language you
can read the math and you can run the
computational language part and if the
math is a piece that is kind of uh done
in for example standard form in wolfram
language it's something that again you
can actually have as something that you
can compute with and and certainly the
things i've been writing about our
physics project and all the other things
i write about uh we they all have click
to copy any picture you see you click it
and it'll give you the code the
computational language code that will
reproduce that picture that is really
valuable and and we can see that in the
development of our physics project for
example we can see how people are
routinely just building on building or
building on the things that have already
been done and that's possible because
there's computational language there
that one can go and just uh and just
take and use and it's also important
that sometimes when you're explaining
something well you could write a bunch
of words and this and that and the other
you could write maybe some mathematical
notation but you can also write
computational language and that's a
unique representation of sort of the
computational uh
way of of saying what you want to say
so you know the way i see it is the
future of things like mathematical
papers and so on eventually
the future will be
uh notebooks and computational notebooks
and computable documents and so on or
effectively computational essays that
eventually has taken a very very very
long time to arrive i mean i started
thinking about those kinds of ideas
probably in the early 1980s and
seriously when we released well when we
were going to release mathematica
probably 1987 or so um really really
locked in on that idea and teo gray was
the person in our team who really
developed this notebook concept
originally as kind of this uh you know
what does it do when you match you know
sort of word processor like technology
with uh computational processing well
you end up with a notebook and and in
fact the the you know the details of
what we invented with cell groups and
closed cells and all that kind of thing
that's i mean that's now 30 a third of a
century old um and and uh that's
something where you know the people have
been producing
notebook-based technical documents
for a third of a century i think the
very first one that i saw produced by an
outside person and published in a
journal was by
a chap
a chap um who was at that time at apple
um
oh gosh i wish i could remember
uh maybe malcolm slaney if i remember
correctly i i apologize if i have that
name wrong um
was um
maybe i have that name wrong sorry um
uh
was a it was a a notebook describing a
model of the cochlear the human cochlea
you can kind of guess at that time why
it might have been interesting i don't
know to
to engineers at apple but um uh
it was sort of the first outside
notebook
uh technical paper published in some
ieee journal in paper form and then
there was a notebook version of it
um
so but that was a third of a century ago
and why hasn't this become more common
well i think it probably hasn't become
more common because people think it's
hard enough to get the words strung
together so somebody can read them but
if we actually have to have
computational language there by golly
it's got to actually run and people can
tell if it runs or not well you can view
that as you know people say well peer
review is this amazing thing because it
you know it
sort of validates the um uh
sort of something about papers i'm not
sure if it really does but that's at
least a view of it well gosh if you had
computational language in papers that's
self-validating at some level because
it's an easy sort of qa test does it run
does it not run does it produce what the
paper says it produces there's so
there's a certain level it's kind of
like a kind of automatic uh sort of
quality control better than peer review
but it's something where stepping up to
that i know when i write things you know
i'm i'm putting code in there sometimes
i get people to help me kind of clean up
the details of how it works for one
reason or another but basically i'm
putting in code
so that every picture that i put in a
document i write has code behind it has
computational language behind it and i
know it takes a certain amount of effort
to do that and make sure that it works
you know the main issue for me is making
sure it works standalone and doesn't
have any dependencies that aren't
included with it and so on and and um
but it's not terribly difficult in in
language it will be exceptionally
difficult if you were doing that in a
programming language because to get to
the point where you can actually write
about something that you probably care
about that isn't just about programming
itself you'd have to have this whole
stack of other kinds of things included
which in wolfram language are just part
of the language but otherwise you'd have
to have this library and that library
and oh are the libraries compatible and
oh what if the libraries were
incompatible with the thing that's
already on your machine it's kind of a
horrifying morass of of of of stuff but
with wolfram language this kind of idea
of computational language is that you
can just put those kinds of things in
so what does that mean
for
the the future of computational
um
papers well there should be a great
future we've been planning to start kind
of a computational journal we've been
planning for like probably 20 years
we've been talking about doing this
we keep on not doing it and part of the
reason we don't do it sometimes i'll run
into ceos of large publishing companies
and things and i'll point out you know
that that few billion dollars of journal
publishing that you're doing you know
you used to add a lot of value by doing
things like typesetting and printing on
paper and things like that um you know
there's a new way to add value which is
to get people to the point where they
can actually publish computational
papers where they can actually have
computational language code that works
and so on but i think nobody has yet
really dived into doing that that's the
future of what used to be that process
of typesetting and copy editing and
proofreading and all those kinds of
things that used to be done and used to
take real work and used to be real value
added by journal publishing that's all
gone away
it should be replaced by the effort to
make computational code computational
language in in papers actually work that
would be a very valuable thing very
useful for people who want to build on
to do what what people in academic
science sort of imagine is the thing one
does which is to take paper a and build
on it paper b and build on that paper c
that's kind of the whole idea of sort of
the academic enterprise and the chains
of citations and all those kinds of
things is to do that but but right now
we're technologically a third of a
century behind
because because it is not a routine
thing yet to actually use computational
language which is what would allow you
to do that kind of progressive building
in an efficient way
and you know eventually that will happen
it's taken a remarkably long time you
know it's also worth remembering or
thinking a little bit about the role of
of sort of publishing and um uh and what
kinds of things people publish you know
the early journals were things like
procedures the royal society from the
1600s people like edmund halley and so
on were big in in the introduction of of
um
of of the of the royal society and the
procedures the royal society and so on
you know i have some some early copies
of the president of the royal society
that some of it is written in english
some of it is in latin uh it's
the the um uh whichever i think it's
mostly in english actually the um
but what's interesting about it is if
you read those documents they mostly
read like blog posts today
they're kind of informal they kind of
explain
uh you know roughly what's going on they
give a little bit of sometimes they even
give a certain amount of like the
natural history ones and things will
give some some kind of uh color about
you know i found the bird it was it was
you know
it was chasing a its tail or whatever
and it you know there'll be a story
around it it won't just be the pure you
know a specimen of latin name latin name
was found in
uh
in a
uh
i i don't know what the what the
appropriate latin version of of chasing
its tail would be but you know a very
formalized version of that would be what
you would see today
and a lot of papers in a lot of fields
it varies with field a bit the
conventions vary with field but one of
the things that that is typical of
academic papers today is is not very
much contextualization of why are you
doing this you know uh sort of the the
the sort of the joke version will be you
know recently smith and jones have done
x
we are going to do x plus a tiny bit
and um uh you know then you have to go
back and look at what smith and jones
did if you want the context you might
have to go back many many layers to get
that context in the earlier history of
this kind of thing the early kind of
journal papers they were like really
what was happening was there was a some
meeting of the royal society and
somebody would stand up and talk about
this or that and that would turn into a
paper read to the royal society and um
that would have a certain informality
which makes it a lot more readable and a
lot more contextualizable
and i think it's sort of a shame that
that stuff has gone away and that to be
sort of academically respectable you uh
you know there's an expectation that you
have this very very dry form
that kind of loses all of the narrative
that i think is super useful often in
understanding
what
uh you know what's going on
now i would say something i haven't seen
you know people have asked me we've done
a lot of live streaming of uh a lot of
both scientific work and and
technological development and so on but
particularly scientific work and people
who ask me should everybody be doing
this you know should universities
routinely be doing this and so on uh you
know
i think it's an interesting possibility
because one of the things that i hadn't
really internalized properly but it's
come up particularly at our summer
schools and things like that is people
say i want to understand you know you
wrote such and such a thing in this
document
okay
why did you write that
well
you know
we've exposed enough material that you
really can tell
in other words you can go and you look
at the working notebook you that's
associated with that you could see what
the what the steps were and then you can
look at the live streamer that was
discussed or even the much more extreme
sort of piece of personal um
uh eccentricity i suppose of mine
are these video work logs that i'm
producing where literally i'm just
sitting down to work
and i set screen recording on
and i'm recording everything i'm doing
i've never looked at them again but uh
you know we're putting those on the web
and you know probably the things i wrote
last night you know i probably spent
four or five hours doing something last
night and and all of that is screen
recorded and so you know if one ever
wanted to know this particular sentence
what on earth was he talking about in
that particular sentence where you can
go back and see what was happening you
know where did that sentence really come
from you actually know the full
provenance and that's something that is
you know modern technology has given us
that opportunity so that's another level
that's kind of the where did it come
from question the the computational
essay you know that's a more where is it
going to type question and that's the
the issue of one of the things that's
great about welfare language and and the
way one can do things is because there's
sort of small fragments of computational
language they're both things humans can
read and you can
context
contactless contextlessly you can just
pick up that lump of water language put
it in a notebook run it it'll produce
the picture you want it to produce
there's no oh i have to load this
library and do this that and the other
it's just the person just like one would
expect if one had defined things
properly that one has a piece of english
that would be in the introduction of
something the one just sort of pick up
and understand without knowing
everything around it
so that's a that's a long um
uh
long description um
of uh
i've almost lost track of what the
original
uh
question oh yeah it was about workflow
for math papers
and i think my main comment there would
be that this computational language
peace is an important piece now i'll
make one more sp that's a general
statement about scientific documents
i'll make one slightly more specific
comment about math in particular
a thing that people
are thinking about is the formalization
of math
at the level that this sort of math one
does to compute things
and there's math one does to prove
things
and
there's
in sort of the way that one thinks about
math in the history of math
vastly more math has been done to
compute things than has been done to
prove things
the idea of math based on proof as well
euclid had that idea
back um uh in antiquity um and
the kind of let's
let's make proofs
i would say really got uh
kind of a
you know it was happening in this you
know even newton modeled his principia
mathematica after euclid
and so that was kind of a motif for
presenting these although he was mostly
presenting physics there
but he presented some mathematics as
well but then
then this kind of idea that math is all
about proof is something that is sort of
a characteristic feature of pure
mathematics it's perhaps a reason why
experimental mathematics has been as as
comparatively invisible as it has is
because the main kind of what you do in
pure mathematics is you state a theorem
and you give its proof and the proof is
kind of there's there's more juice to
the proof than just saying oh i can you
know
trust me it's true type thing
in a good proof the proof is the
exposition of what's going on now in
modern times we also have automated
proofs
you know a surprising thing there are
automated proofs that people do
and
particularly they're useful for things
like automated proofs of protocols and
correctness of programs and things like
that but when it comes to math a
surprising fact is that i don't believe
that any
i believe there's only one example of an
unexpected result in math that was found
by automated theory improving and it was
something that i found in the year 2000
which is this
minimal axiom system for boolean algebra
which is surprising unexpected and i
found it completely with automated
theorem proving
and one feature of that proof is it's a
big long complicated proof generated by
a machine and utterly incomprehensible
to people and not useful as a piece of
communication
but in any case one of the things that
people are now talking about is insofar
as the the practice of pure mathematics
is about the presentation of proofs can
we maybe present those proofs in a in
more of a computational language type
style
as something where you can
systematically build on pieces of proofs
okay so i think the thing that tends to
get missed there
is to make that useful and usable you
have to do a bunch of language design in
other words you need to say oh we've got
this thing and it's a graph what does it
actually mean that it's a graph how is
it actually set up what is its notation
how does it work that's an important
piece and that's a piece that is the
strange
art science of language design that i
personally have been very involved in
now for for 40 years and it's a very
language design you know i i do a bunch
of things i you know i think some of the
things i do are quite intellectually
difficult
i think the one that is the pinnacle of
intellectual difficulty is language
design and there's a reason for that
because language design is really about
how do you take ideas and crispen them
to the maximum extent how do you really
understand the essence of ideas in a
certain way and that's and so language
design is hard and a big piece of what's
necessary in successful formalization of
proof style mathematics is language
design and we've started we tried about
six or seven years ago we had quite an
initiative to try to get mathematicians
and so on to help define that language
for pure mathematics i think in
wolverine language we may maybe have
seven thousand primitive constructs at
this point i think with another thousand
to fifteen hundred we would cover sort
of all of of standard current pure
mathematics but what those what those
thousand or fifteen hundred primitives
really should be that's a lot of work to
figure out a lot of judgment a lot of
language design a lot of understanding
the essence of things it's difficult
stuff
and we tried to kind of get that to be
something that will be a thing in the
mathematics community and although we
have many friends in the mathematics
community a lot people use that
technology all the time we really people
didn't really care very much it wasn't
something where people were saying
oh you know we're pure mathematicians we
we would really like this to to pursue
our art and actually in recent times as
i've understood more about meta
mathematics and about foundations of
math and that'll be something i'll be
talking about a bunch more in a few
weeks i hope um will be um i've sort of
understood why this is that this drive
towards accidentization that people like
hilbert were really pushing 100 years
ago or so
is is a drive in a direction of
mathematics that is a different
direction than what most pure
mathematicians think they're doing for
most people mathematicians they're
they're drawing in brush strokes
the the analogy that i have is the level
of axiomatic mathematics of grinding
through specific axioms and proofs and
so on is like molecular dynamics it's
like a bunch of molecules bouncing
around in a gas the level of mathematics
that's done by
a working human pure mathematician is
more at the level of fluid mechanics you
know the big brush strokes not the
precise details of which where every
bristle of every brush went and
precisely how was it arranged and so
that's um
uh in any case but the the concept
that's arisen is this notion of not
automated theorem proving where you say
here's a theorem now go generate the
proof but more proof assistance well
what you're saying is i'm going to
produce these pieces of sort of asserted
to be true things in mathematics
now let me make sort of put together the
puzzle build up the tower based on those
sort of lego pieces or something to get
to the thing that i want to get to and
so this is the idea of proof assistance
and sometimes they'll have sort of auto
suggestions that might be even based on
some automated film proving or might be
based on calling mathematica or
something to say you know what is the
the thing that i should add next so to
speak
um but that's kind of an idea for how to
build up kind of a formalized structure
of mathematics
um
i'm
you know is this the future of
mathematics i'm skeptical i think that
it's a it's a it's an interesting thing
to do it's been most useful in areas
like protocol verification and things
like that
in the sort of more computational areas
there are certainly cases where
oh you know
tom hales when he was proving the
coupler conjecture um you know people
didn't believe his proof it actually he
made quite a lot of use of our
technology and his proof and and did
it's a surprisingly complicated proof of
a claim that kepler had made that you
could that the closest packing of
spheres is the standard um packing that
you see of fruit and grocery stores so
to speak that had been never proved
and tom hales came up with the proof but
then you know it was a big long paper
and the mathematics community was like
oh we don't understand this you know are
you sure you really got it right and he
basically said no i'm going to make a
proof of system he spent a decade doing
that make a proof assistant system which
which can actually brick by brick
establish that this thing is
definitively and firmly true
um and uh
but i'm not not sure how much you know
what do we learn from this you know it's
a
better than automated proof in the sense
that it was a human-constructed thing
but and it does presumably tell some
kind of story but it's a story that has
been uh i don't know it's a it's not a
story that seems to be as useful as one
might hope
so you know that that's another
direction for kind of the the uh the
sort of the future of presentation of
math is this idea of the kind of
formalized proof i personally think that
you know in the efforts that we've made
to build wolfram language and make it a
computational language that's good for
humans to read that's a critical idea if
you really want humans to read
computational stuff you've got to do the
art of the thing as well to make it so
that that's something that has humans
can really uh you know
it where there's sort of clarity of
exposition is part of the design of the
system and i'm not sure that that's been
understood yet in the case of of kind of
the proof assistant world but i think
that's a necessary piece whether that is
the correct way to think about the
foundations of mathematics whether
that's a correct way to think about kind
of how progress should really be made in
mathematics that's a different question
i'll probably have more to say about
that in a few weeks um because i've been
working uh quite actively on on
on on kind of mathematics and the
foundations of mathematics
all right unfortunately i'm really late
um
uh
oh there's a one question here i'm gonna
address from john how can we be sure
that the software generating the proof
is correct
well you see the nice thing about
automated proofs is
you get kind of a a proof function
that is a thing where for example
uh in the automated proof of the uh
simplest axiom for boolean algebra
the um the proof is basically a series
of steps where you're substituting
one expression into another expression
you're just doing that hundreds of times
and eventually you get the result
okay so it was difficult to find that
series of substitutions to do that's the
art of finding the proof that's what the
automated theorem brewing system does
but once you've found the series of
substitutions
any old dumb machine can go and do those
substitutions so you have typically you
can have many different
very straightforward differently written
pieces of code that just go through and
just do the substitutions and so that's
the way that you would validate
um
the uh
uh that's the way that you validate
um
the uh uh the proof and that's a
straightforward thing to do and that
doesn't depend on oh did your automated
theorem proving system which may be a
quite complicated quite heuristic piece
of code did it hiccup at some point
doesn't matter because if the if the
series of substitutions it defines you
can run through those and validate that
it's correct and that's an easy thing to
do hard to find the proof easy to check
the proof it's actually the original the
original paper on mp completeness by
stephen cook in 1971 was actually about
proofs and was about this very point
that it's can be hard to make a proof
but easy to check it
right i think that's that's it for today
uh tomorrow we have some other live
streams about completely different
topics
um
and uh
look forward to um
uh
seeing you all again another live stream
there'll be um
and
friday
is my
uh science and technology q a for kids
and others
and then this time next week we are
alternating between history of science
and technology
and business innovation and managing
life q a
all right well thanks for joining me if